[Música]
el aborto se despenaliza en colombia con
cinco votos a favor y cuatro en contra
la corte constitucional decidió que la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo se
puede hacer en todos los casos hasta la
semana número 24 de gestación
conectaremos con bogotá
ollanta humala es el primer ex
presidente peruano en ser juzgado por el
escándalo de odebrecht el antiguo
mandatario podría pagar hasta 20 años de
cárcel si se prueba que recibió dinero
de la compañía brasileña para sus
campañas presidenciales de 2006 y 2011
tenemos información desde lima
los incendios forestales en el noreste
de argentina y en paraguay siguen en una
situación altamente crítica las llamas
ya han arrasado más de 600 mil hectáreas
argentinas y están amenazando al humedal
más grande de ese país
bienvenidos a esta emisión dedicada a
las noticias de américa mi nombre es
marie claire a calle y es un placer
saludarlos y comenzamos en colombia la
corte constitucional despenalizó el
aborto durante las primeras 24 semanas
de gestación antes de esto las mujeres
sólo podían abortar en tres escenarios
cuando estuviera en riesgo la salud de
la madre cuando el feto tuviera una
malformación grave o cuando el embarazo
fuera producto de una violación nuestra
periodista marinas ardilla nos ampliaba
previamente desde bogotá
colombia logra un avance histórico con
la despenalización del aborto hasta la
semana 24 del embarazo este lunes la
corte constitucional colombiana votó con
5 favor y 4 en contra la despenalización
del aborto hasta la semana 24 recordemos
que en el país el aborto estaba
permitido dentro de un sistema de tres
causales si había riesgo para la vida de
la mujer se había malformación del feto
o en caso de violación a partir de ahora
el aborto está despenalizado hasta la
semana 24 un logro histórico ya que a
las puertas de la corte constitucional
de colombia las feministas y los
movimientos que han estado luchando por
este derecho de las mujeres están
celebrando en un día histórico que marca
un precedente para la región puesto que
colombia se convierte así en uno de los
países con las leyes menos restrictivas
respecto a la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo y tenemos con nosotros a
mariana ry la ella es abogada de la
organización women's link quien impulsó
esta demanda frente a la corte de
constitucional
cuéntame qué supone este día para
ustedes las colombianas y las
organizaciones que habían luchado por
este derecho bueno es un día histórico
es un fallo que es un hito en el mundo y
en américa latina' con esto quedamos con
la legislación más protectora y más
avanzada en temas de interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo de américa
latina y una de las pocas del mundo que
tiene esta regulación y esto va a
cambiar la vida de muchas mujeres niñas
y adolescentes que no es no son
privilegiadas que están en alta
vulnerabilidad y que antes tenían que ir
recurrir a abortos inseguros y arriesgar
su vida hoy pueden al menos hasta la
semana 24 y después con las causales ir
de forma segura tranquila sin miedo a
ser denunciadas al sistema de salud y
eso nos va a permitir protegerlas
colombia entonces despenaliza el aborto
sale fuera del código penal hasta la
semana 24 y hoy las feministas
colombianas están celebrando en las
calles acá en bogotá
y poder judicial de perú inició el
juicio oral contra el ex mandatario
ollanta humala por presunto lavado de
dinero en las campañas electorales de
2006 y 2011 así se convierte en el
primer ex presidente peruano llevado a
juicio por aportes de odebrecht y es que
lo acusa de supuestamente haber recibido
dinero de esta empresa brasileña y del
gobierno de venezuela para financiar su
candidatura presidencial desde el iba a
nuestro corresponsal francisco zacarías
no se ampliaba más temprano la
información
la justicia peruana inició el juicio por
lavado de activos al ex presidente
ollanta humala ya su esposa nadine
heredia a quien la fiscalía acusa de
presunta financiación ilegal de las
campañas electorales de 2006 con 200 mil
dólares que habrían sido enviados por el
entonces presidente de venezuela hugo
chávez y en el año 2011 el ministerio
público afirma que los humala habrían
recibido aportes de las constructoras
brasileñas o de 'break' y base la
defensa plantea la inocencia de humala y
su esposa y en una primera estrategia
fue solicitar a la corte la postergación
del inicio del juicio porque pedían más
tiempo para revisar cuatro tomos que se
agregaron al expediente del caso que se
afirma tiene más de cuatro mil páginas y
señalaban que no existía garantías para
un proceso transparente el tribunal
rechazó el pedido esta es también el
primer juicio que se realiza a un
expresidente peruano por el caso de
sobornos de 'break' la fiscalía ha
solicitado 20 años de prisión para el ex
presidente ollanta humala y 26 años de
cárcel para su esposa nadine heredia el
equipo de fiscales quiere usar como
pruebas agendas de heredia en los que se
identifica fechas y el dinero que
ingresaba en las campañas presidenciales
del tercer juzgado penal colegiado
nacional programó para este martes la
continuación de la audiencia la fiscalía
dispondrá de tres horas para presentar
los alegatos contra humala y sus
coacusados diversos juristas sostienen
que va a ser muy difícil para ollanta
humala probar su inocencia y quizás si
la justicia lo encuentra culpable se
convertiría en el primer expresidente
peruano condenado por corrupción
argentina desplegó cerca de 160
brigadistas para luchar contra los
incendios forestales que hay en las
provincias de corrientes y de misiones
un escenario similar se vive en paraguay
donde las que más afectan también la
producción de soya y la calidad del aire
mis seis aviones tres helicópteros
159 brigadistas y todo el personal de
apoyo convocado por el servicio
argentino de manejo del fuego logran
contener los incendios forestales que
azotan las provincias de corrientes y
misiones desde enero por lo que el
gobierno pidió ayuda a estados unidos
brasil y bolivia y corrientes llama la
atención de toda la argentina obviamente
acaba de vivir una tragedia corrientes
tenemos puesto todas nuestras fuerzas
para ayudar porque la argentina es una
no hay una argentina de accidentes en
argentina periférica no hay pueblitos y
ciudades hay argentinos que necesitan de
que en argentina se levante
más de 600 mil hectáreas ya fueron
consumidas por las llamas entre los
argentinos hay especial preocupación por
las plantaciones de yerba mate crucial
en su dieta que se encuentran en
corrientes paraguay que limita con esa
provincia argentina también se ha visto
afectada por el fuego este país el
cuarto exportador de soja en el mundo
advirtió que la cosecha puede disminuir
hasta un 60% este año eso significa
aproximadamente entre 2500 y 3000
millones de dólares menos que no van a
ingresar a nuestra economía los
productores de carne también temen que
la escasez de pastos genere cuantiosas
pérdidas entretanto las autoridades
alertaron que la calidad del aire es
crítica en asuncion por lo que el
ministerio de salud recomendó permanecer
en el interior con puertas y ventanas
cerradas
en canadá el parlamento aprobó la
prórroga de la ley de emergencias que
invocó el primer ministro georges título
para frenar las manifestaciones de los
transportistas en contra de las medidas
por el kobe 19 finalmente con 185 votos
a favor y 151 en contra los poderes
fueron aprobados esto prohibir a la
financiación a los manifestantes y
permitirá que sus vehículos sean
remolcados por las autoridades
en ciudad de méxico podrían quedar
prohibidas las corridas de toros la
iniciativa es promovida por legisladores
en la asamblea de local para evitar que
se maten animales y que sean objeto de
maltrato y crueldad sin embargo primero
hay intereses económicos y comerciales
que podrían complicar la erradicación de
estas prácticas elisa chávez tiene el
informe
las corridas de toros podrían
desaparecer en ciudad de mexico el
bastión de la tauromaquia en américa
latina' por primera vez el congreso
local votó para abolir esta práctica los
animales son sintientes y cuando
nos damos cuenta de eso cambia la óptica
los animales ya no son cosas los
animales son esos seres sintientes que
tienen derechos sin embargo los empleos
y el comercio que genera la llamada
fiesta brava han frenado hasta ahora la
prohibición según datos de la secretaría
de agricultura de méxico para el 2018 la
industria taurina movió 343 millones de
dólares generó 80.000 empleos directos
146 mil indirectos y movilizó a más de
50 mil espectadores ante las críticas
por el maltrato animal los toreros
aseguran que las corridas son el final
más digno para los toros lo que te puedo
decir desde mi punto de vista
es que todo todo el conjunto del arte
que es la tauromaquia tiene que terminar
de esa manera no el toro tiene que tiene
que terminar así gracias a dios ese es
un arte en el que yo también estoy
entregando mi vida no para que se
apruebe la eliminación de la tauromaquia
falta una votación en el pleno del
congreso local que aún no tiene fecha
hasta el momento en cuatro estados
mexicanos
se prohíben las corridas de toros y en
otros siete son patrimonio cultural
mientras que en latinoamérica aún son
permitidas ampliamente en paraguay perú
y venezuela- parcialmente en ecuador
bolivia y colombia y prohibidas en
brasil uruguay chile y argentina- así
llegamos al final de esta emisión los
invitamos a que sigan conectados con
france24
[Música]